you'll remember five cyclists were
killed on u.s 95 near a searchlight back
in december and since then
advocates and loved ones are doing what
they can to prevent another tragedy
bianca holman is live from the ghost
bike memorial in downtown summerlin with
more on their efforts good morning
bianca
hey good morning alex good morning john
so this memorial here the ghost bike
memorial
is to remind folks to move over and to
protect our cyclists there are some of
our most vulnerable folks on the roads
and so again they're encouraging people
to pay attention drivers to be vigilant
so that another tragedy like we saw in
december doesn't happen
again now over the past year retailers
they sold
through a year's worth of inventory in
just a few months and while it's great
that more folks are taking up cycling it
also means more cyclists are on our
roads
the southern nevada bicycle coalition
has a cyclist-specific education
campaign for many of these new riders
andrew bennett with department of safety
says drivers also need to be more
responsible
move over and share the road
it comes down to accountability
responsibility and also making sure that
you're watching for the cyclists
you know i've got kids and always you
know you play slug bug
you just play sub cyclists you know if
you see a cyclist you you should say it
in the car
you know build the accountability and
get used to looking for vulnerable road
users
the majority of the motoring public
understand that we have several
different move over laws whether it's
for
emergency vehicles on the side of the
road cyclists approaching
emergency vehicles you know move to the
right that's not the problem
at the end of the day it comes down to
accountability responsibility and
respect for life
all right so that event and press event
is going to be later this morning at 8
30 at the las vegas cyclery again
they'll be sharing
new education a new campaign and various
events that are going to be happening
and coming up
about again ride safe again knowing
before you go and keeping our cyclists
safe on the roads bianca holman
reporting from downtown summerlin 8 news
now